ask about what happens that from june
are we going to need a covert status
certificate
to go to the pub or to go to a shop you
said that we won't need one before june
the 21st what about
after that though well very important to
to stress that
the best thing of all is to vaccinate
our population
get everybody out getting the the jab
that's the
the key thing and that's what i would uh
advocate number one
uh the second point obviously is that on
the
on monday on the 12th uh shops are going
to be open
outdoor beer gardens
outdoor restaurants and so on you don't
need anything at
any kind of certificate to go then you
won't need anything on
on may the 17th when we open up indoor
hospitality in restaurants indoor pubs
no question anything then
what of course we're looking at is what
several other countries
are looking at and that's the role of
vaccination passports for overseas
travel i think that is going to be a
factor of a fact of life
probably a lot of other countries are
looking at that
i think we're also going to look at the
role of
a number of of signals that you can give
that you're not contagious so first of
all
your immunity if you've had it uh
that's going to be important another two
uh vaccination will be will be useful
but don't forget also the importance of
testing so
from uh the ninth from friday uh
everybody can get free
lateral flow tests also on the uh on the
nhs and
on the web on over the internet uh and i
think that will also be very very
valuable in
giving people confidence to open up tell
us about lateral flow tests in terms of
people returning from countries that are
green on the traffic light system
because the boss of easyjet
this morning said that the plans for
testing requirements for international
travelers returning are too expensive at
the moment so why not
allow travellers returning from green
light countries to do a lateral flow
test instead of the more expensive
alternatives
you know i i raised that very issue uh
myself uh yesterday i i do think we want
to make things as
as easy as as we possibly can i i think
there is a
uh the the boss of easyjet is is
is is right to focus on this issue we're
gonna see what we can do
uh to uh make things as you know as
flexible and as
affordable as as possible i do want to
see
international travel start up again we
have to be realistic
a lot of the destinations that we want
to go to at the moment
are suffering a new wave of of the
illness of of covered
as as we know uh it's not gonna uh
you know we can't do it immediately uh
but that doesn't mean that we've
we've given up on on may the 17th we'll
we'll be saying uh as much as we can as
soon as we can about international
travel
i know how impatient uh people are to
uh to book uh their their holidays if
they possibly can
but you know i think we we just have to
be prudent
at this stage finally